[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días un
programa semanal en el que analizamos la
actualidad más destacada del continente
africano comenzamos con los titulares en
el giro de 180 grados contra el aparato
militar ruso chef Jenny prigó sin
comandante del grupo Wagner mencionó
África vemos como el continente se ha
transformado en los últimos años en la
plataforma de lanzamiento del grupo y de
su líder
Aún se espera justicia para las víctimas
de la tragedia de melilla cuando decenas
de migrantes perdieron brutalmente la
vida intentando cruzar a España un año
después ni Marruecos ni España han
realizado investigaciones para
esclarecer lo sucedido
Y por último vamos a senegal el país
como todos los países del Mundo musulmán
celebrará a finales de este mes la
fiesta del sacrificio en esta edición
les contamos la pasión de los senegales
es por los carneros conocidos Como el
adum
el sábado 24 de junio
jefe del grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner
que hasta entonces había combatido en el
frente ucraniano junto al ejército de
Vladimir Putin dio un giro de 180 grados
y se volvió contra su Aliado acusa al
aparato militar ruso de proporcionar de
no proporcionar al grupo el apoyo
logístico necesario pero también acusa
alnda abandonar a Wagner en África y de
desviar los fondos destinados a ayudar a
los países del continente en particular
Mali y la república centroafricana Y es
que desde hace varios años va a tener a
desarrollado una fuerte presencia en el
continente africano veamos
en su ajuste de cuentas con el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin y sus
fuerzas armadas el jefe del grupo
paramilitar Wagner jefyang yen no se
olvidó de mencionar a África luchábamos
en África Porque nos dijeron que
necesitábamos a África y luego
abandonaron el continente robaron todo
el dinero que se suponía que iba a
servir para ayudar a los países
africanos desde los años 2017 y 2018
África ha servido de plataforma de
lanzamiento para el meteórico ascenso
del grupo y de su líder
Wagner ha conseguido expandirse por
varios países africanos siempre con la
misma estrategia proteger a los
regímenes de turno con el argumento de
luchar contra el terrorismo a cambio de
un dominio absoluto sobre los recursos
de los países pero las actividades del
grupo cuyas operaciones y orígenes
siguen siendo en gran medida opacos no
se limitan al ámbito militar
de la propaganda hasta la minería
pasando por los negocios la presencia
del grupo está atestiguada en una
quincena de países africanos con
mercenarios desplegados en al menos tres
de ellos En Mali se cree que hay al
menos 1400 mercenarios rusos y también
hay cerca de un millar en Libia y en la
República centroafricana la República
centroafricana es precisamente el
bastión original de Wagner en el
continente
en 2018 el grupo fue responsable de
entrenar al ejército y proporcionar
seguridad al presidente fontanacans a
cambio Wagner tuvo vía libre para
servirse de las riquezas del país oro
diamantes madera entre otros recursos
luego el grupo replicó este mismo modelo
en Mali dondequiera que se instala
Wagner recurre a una retórica
antioccidental y prorrosa avivando sobre
todo el sentimiento anti francés burkina
faso donde el gobierno de transición
intenta establecer Su autoridad las
banderas rusas han aparecido en las
calles el pasado diciembre el gobierno
de burkina faso invocó el apoyo de Moscú
en la lucha contra el terrorismo pero
las principales víctimas del grupo
paramilitar siguen siendo los civiles
desde su llegada a África Los
mercenarios rusos han sido responsables
de numerosos actos de violencia contra
la población civil
y en cuanto al futuro del grupo en el
Continente Después de llegar a un
acuerdo con el kremlin aseguró que Rusia
continuaría sus operaciones en África
y central en ese momento tanto la
República centroafricana como Mali
fueron abandonados por los franceses y
otros europeos esos suspendieron el
trabajo de sus regimientos
antiterroristas cerraron sus bases
militares que debían apoyar la lucha
antiterrorista dadas esas condiciones
cuando se vieron cara a cara con los
criminales tanto la República
centroafricana como líder recurrieron a
la empresa militar privada Wagner le
pidieron que protegiera a sus gobiernos
a raíz de este llamado varios centenares
de militares rusos están trabajando en
la República centroafricana como
instructores este trabajo por supuesto
continuará
pasamos a otro tema así casi un año
varios centenares de migrantes
intentaron cruzar el paso fronterizo de
melilla que separa Marruecos de España
el intento fue violentamente reprimido
por las autoridades y decenas de
personas murieron o siguen desaparecidas
hasta el día de hoy un año después de
los hechos la organización de Derechos
Humanos amnistía internacional ha
acusado a España y Marruecos de
encubrimiento por no haber llevado a
cabo una investigación adecuada la ong
crítico también a las autoridades de
Marruecos por no haber repatriado los
cuerpos de las víctimas y por no haber
facilitado una lista de las personas
fallecidas con la causa de su muerte los
detalles los tiene Sofía catala nuestra
corresponsal en Marruecos
a un año de la masacre de melilla No hay
ninguna investigación abierta ni en
España ni en Marruecos para juzgar a los
responsables de la mayor tragedia jamás
vivida en la frontera de este enclave
español el 24 de junio de 2022 murieron
al menos 23 personas en dicha frontera
según las autoridades 40 personas Según
a las organizaciones de defensa de
Derechos Humanos todo aconteció cuando
la policía trató de impedir por la
fuerza que cerca de 2.000 migrantes y
demandantes de asilo lograrán cruzar las
vallas que separan Marruecos de España
desde ese día también hay cerca de 80
personas desaparecidas y a pesar de la
violencia 470 personas lograron ese día
acceder a territorio español y fueron
expulsadas de forma inmediata y sin
ningún tipo de garantías de nuevo hacia
el país magrebí en Marruecos decenas de
supervivientes acabaron encarcelados
cargando con toda la responsabilidad de
lo que ocurrió ese día en la frontera
Los condenaron por los delitos de
ultraje a las autoridades favorecer la
inmigración clandestina entre otros
cargos y el resto de personas fueron
trasladadas de forma forzada a regiones
alejadas de la frontera española la
mayoría de personas afectadas por la
masacre de melilla son demandantes de
asilo que huyen de la guerra
concretamente de la guerra de Sudán y se
encuentran bloqueados aquí en Marruecos
este país no les ofrece asilo ni
asistencia e impide su avance hacia
Europa Y es que Marruecos se recibe
cantidades millonarias para impedir que
personas migrantes y refugiadas puedan
acceder a territorio europeo solamente
España en los últimos cinco años ha
pagado más de 120 millones de euros a su
país vecino para reforzar el control
migratorio y por su parte la Unión
Europea prevé inyectar al país magrebí
más de 500 millones de euros hasta el
año 2027 ya un año de la masacre de Meli
ya los supervivientes y sus familias así
como las organizaciones de defensa de
Derechos Humanos exigen vías legales
para poder Acceder al asilo para poder
acceder a la justicia y también verdad y
reparación
vamos a otro país los carneros más caros
del mundo se encuentran en senegal en
África occidental donde se los llama la
dum esos carneros conocidos por sus
dimensiones excepcionales pueden costar
hasta 80 mil dólares su carne es muy
apreciada por los más adinerados durante
el sacrificio de la festividad musulmana
de quevir celebrada a finales de este
mes pero las familias más Humildes
también suelen comprar uno en un país
donde la ganadería es una pasión este
animal lo deja a nadie indiferente
veamos el reportaje en Dakar de Sara
sacó la maraña
es el nombre de mi hermano mayor con el
que bromeo todo el tiempo
115 centímetros y más de 100 kilos hay
un es un ladún un carnero de lujo que
encanta los senegaleses particularmente
durante y del que vivir la religiosa más
importante del país donde es costumbre
sacrificar un animal y para la fiesta
Nada mejor que un ladún según este
hombre su belleza sus cuernos su
crecimiento son espectaculares y a la
gente le encanta regalárselos a su líder
religioso o a sus seres queridos No hay
mejor regalo que un ladún un regalo por
el que algunos no dudan en pagar miles
de dólares una fortuna en un país donde
el salario medio no supera los 100
dólares
abdu regresa por tercera vez a esta
tienda para negociar precios finalmente
pagó cuatro mil dólares por tres
carneros
su carne es deliciosa y el hecho de
tener un lado en casa trae una sensación
de alegría por Su carisma su tamaño les
encanta a los niños porque son los
únicos carneros con esa complexión
física
en este edificio de
en senegal los más bellos ejemplares de
la doom no están destinados a la venta
sino a la reproducción aquí los carneros
reciben el mejor cuidado limpieza
alimento incluso masaje nada es
demasiado para estos huéspedes de lujo
este macho de 120 centímetros es el
orgullo de su criador
es un carnero mejorado en África
particularmente en senegal tenemos pocas
razas de ovejas y para obtener más
especies cruzamos varias razas para
obtener este resultado
que de año en senegal un concurso de
belleza previa a los animales más
hermosos
llegamos al final de nuestro programa
Gracias por acompañarnos la actualidad
internacional sigue en France 24 y
France 24.com